I went to law school and I was like I'm
gonna make it rain in the dough and
that's not happening at all
[Music]
that's a great question I think cuz you
can flip them that way it's because it
makes us feel like fancy lawyers like an
objection flip and so longer
aren't they longer you know what they
also don't have holes yeah they don't
have holes in them yeah as soon as pens
can't get stuck we've stressed out I
love my job I really like what I do now
like everyone hates it no maybe they
should stop being lawyers then if they
hate their job because they're stressed
super super highly stressed out people a
lot of pressure you're dealing with like
peoples like the most important part of
people's lives there so for some people
like the biggest thing that's happened I
defend people who are facing evictions
so my case the outcome of it will
determine if a person has a home or not
and that's a lot of pressure that drink
a lot of juice
Tino's not like alcohol well let's not
lie objection we don't act I've never
once said objection you have to preserve
the objections guys what are you
objecting opposing counsel does simple
thing that they're not supposed to do
you know how many lawyers are really in
depth oh or trials and you've got to
preserve in the depo the only time I
yell out objection is when my
boyfriend's talking nonsense
the only time I ever use that in my
career
I think people hate us because a lot of
lawyers on TV are super rich and smuggle
money and they're like the ones that
defend the asbestos people gonna blame
TV for the lawyer hatred yeah I don't
know I don't know where to pinpoint it
TV I've looked this one up
you also go a little bit I did it I
googled this so hard because my sister
was running her mouth and I was like
stop I'm a doctor and she goes no you're
not
and I was stood up and I was like no
she's right and she's wrong we have our
JD so we're juris doctors but we're not
allowed to use it in the United States
because it would present a misleading
type of role to the public by saying we
have more education than we actually do
have so we wouldn't be the equivalent to
like a medical doctor and you can get
your doctorate of law which is like even
higher I looked into that because I
wanted to be it for every student and
then I was like nah homie I'm not
messing with that
I object % cuz let me fight a lot of
debt so much that on my salary I cannot
afford a nice services and it's not dope
at all my first-year law school I was
told do not late date another lawyer and
that's what I did
this lawyer dates a low voltage
electrician because it has nothing to do
with law I majored in sociology
I majored in criminal justice and
history but a lot of lawyers major in
like philosophy or English or something
like that it doesn't matter business
engineer surprisingly do really well on
the bar exam math majors to do really
well anything really it doesn't matter
[Music]
lawyers can help people a lot like there
are a lot of volunteer opportunities and
pro bono opportunities I don't know how
many actually do it but I know that good
amount there's a lot of potential there
to help all I do is help it's nice I
[Music]
cannot count it counting to ten today
was a struggle one of my clients came
and said they had an illegal rent
increase so I had to figure out the math
and I just didn't I had somebody else to
do it cuz I don't know what percent it's
like I don't know that lawyers don't
like math no that's why we're lawyers
I think it's unethical for us to lie and
it comes a point to lie I think people
think we're like hiding evidence and
like throwing the gun in the ocean and
like no that's because we watched how to
get a robbery yeah we can lose our
license for lying that's not cool we do
zealously advocate but no lies
[Music]
yeah yes
we usually get kicked off have you ever
in San Francisco I saw a trial where
they had like not kidding three lawyers
on their way yeah san Francisco's dope
it is but yes you can serve on jury duty
[Music]
[Music]